قراءتك
ل سحب هذه الكتيبه الكتيبه رقم 13 التي
قتل منها 42 جنديا منها قائدان لهذه
الكتيبه سحبها في هذا
التوقيت زين العابدين اولا عندما تخرج
وحده عسكريه من مركز قتال اساسي يعني
نتحدث عن الشجاعيه شجعيه يعني هي مركز
الثقل الاساسي التي يسعى الى ليسيطر عليه
الجيش اسرائيلي هذا يعني انها اما وصلت
الى مرحله لم تعد قادره على القتال لا
عديدا ولا عتادا ولا حتى معنويات وبالتالي
وجب سحبها لاعاده تنظيمها ولكنها لن تعاد
الى الخدمه مرح سريعه لماذا لانه من قتل
منها
يج اعاده ترتيبها تكوينها يعني اعاده ملء
الفراغات فيها ان كان في العتاد او العديد
العديد وحتى في التدريب لانه عندما يدخل
الى هذه الفرقه او الى هذه الكتيبه عناصر
جدد يجب ان يكون هناك اعاده تدريب مع
الباقين لخلق روح الوحده كما يقال
بالاضافه الى التعويض بالعتاد وهذا امر
صعب هذا لن يحصل في الايام القادمه
يعني حسب ما جريده الهارتس من اسبوع انه
الجيش الاسرائيلي لاول مره منذ تاريخ
لم يقاتل هكذا نوع من القتال في منطقه
سكنيه لهذه الفتره وهذا الامر
كبد الجيش الاسرائيلي خاصه الجولاني وخاصه
هذه الكتيبه العديد من القتلى والمعدات
ايضا وهنا نعود الى بيان ابو عبيده الذي
تحدث عن 720 اليه ما بين دبابه ميركافا
وعربه نمر وجرافات وناقلات جند و سيارات
شحن هذا عدد
كبير بالطبع لانه خصائص هذه المعركه زين
العابدين هي خصائص مختلفه لماذا اليوم
الجيش الاسرائيلي يسعى الى الاشتباك مع
العدو
واذهاب الى معركه حاسمه عبر الالتفاف عبر
المناوره وبالتالي الانتهاء منها بسرعه
وهذا الامر لم تعطيه حماس ل الجيش
الاسرائيلي هي تقاتل عبر الكمائن من بيت
الى بيت وعبر الاغارات كما حصل في جحر
الديك فاذا انت للحفاظ
على جنوده بدا يدخل الى المناطق السكنيه
بالاليات من نمر وحتى الايتان وحتى
الميركافا ومن الضروري ان يكون معها اليات
للاخلاء او لفتح الطرق مثل الجرافه وهذا
يعود الى كتيبه الهن الهندسه الموجوده في
اللواء فاذا انت تدخل الى منطقه لا تعرفها
كي تقاتل يصبح هذا المكان زين العابدين
غني بالاهداف الاساسيه يعني نحن راينا ال
القسام والمقاومه تصور فيديوهات عن عن
الاشتباك على المسافه السفريه ولم نرى
الاسرائيلي يصور هذه الامور لماذا لانه
انت تكمن له انت تعرفه اين يذهب واين وكيف
يتحرك وعدد الاليات وبالتالي انت قادر
على التصوير للهدف الاعلامي وبالتالي
القدره على ضرب هذه الاليات وليس بالضروره
ان تكون هذه الاليات زين العابدين دمرت
بالكامل يكفي ان تعطوها لتكون مكانها يكفي
ان يصاب الجندي في يده او في رجله ليكون
خارج القتال نحن تحدثنا عن عدد القتلى
ولكن لم نتحدث عن عدد الجرحى ومدى نسبه
الجروح لهؤلاء الجنود اه نحن نتحدث يعني
اذا كانت الصحف الاسرائليه تحدثت عن 5000
هذا قبل اسبوع او اكثر من الجنود بينهم ال
اعاقه الان يعني ما المتوقع بالنسبه لعدد
القتلى وبالنسبه لعدد الاليات ما المتوقع
ان يكون عليه الخسائر في صفوف الجنود
والضباط الاسرائيليين سواء كانت كانوا
قتلى او
مصابين زين العابدين نتحدث عن 5000 يعني
5000 اصبحوا خارج الخدمه منهم من هو
المعطوب اعاقه دائمه هذا انتهى امره يجب
الاهتمام فيه على فتره فترات طويله وهذا
امر يكلف الدوله الاسرائيليه المبالغ
الطائله وهناك الجريح الذي قد يذهب الى
وحدات لا تقاتل وبالتالي الجريح العادي
الذي يطبب ويعود ولكن ال 5000 هي خارج
اطار ال خارج اطار القتال الاساسي يعني
الجولاني خمس خه كتائب خمسه كتائب 1000
تقريبا الف عدد الجنود بالكتيبه عم نتحدث
عن لواء كامل وشامل من كل القطع
الاسرائيليه اصبحت خارج الخدمه وهذا امر
يعتبر صعب اصلا خاصه في مجتمع مثل المجتمع
الاسرائيلي الذي يؤله ويكرم الجيش الى
درجه متقدمه اشكرك شكرا جزيلا من بيروت
العميد الياس حنا الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي